il y à bien plus d'un char d'un soldat
ou d'un avion en ce 11 septembre 1973
pour détruire le palais de la moneda
dans quelques minutes le locataire des
lieux salvatore allende va mourir le
général pinochet s'empare du pouvoir et
impose une dictature qui d'entrée se
donne les moyens de perdurer
pineau chez dissous le parlement suspend
les partis politique proscrit le
communisme se proclame chef suprême de
la nation
plus tard viendra l'état de siège et
malheur aux opposants ici on arrête là
on tire sur des civils sans vraiment se
cacher devenu président de la république
pinochet prendra pour habitude de
regrouper les suspects dans le stade de
santiago
dernière étape avant l'assassinât ou la
disparition
combien de victimes trois quatre mille
suffisamment en tout cas pour que des
mères des pères des enfants brandissent
le portrait d'un proche et interroge
où est il mais la dictature et forte
efficace a noyé la contestation
en fait pinochet ne quittera le pouvoir
que parce qu'il aura bien voulu
il procède par étapes en 89
il n'est plus président de la république
mais il reste commandant en chef de
l'armée de terre
cela durera neuf ans avant que le 10
mars dernier ils finissent par se
contenter d'un titre de sénateur à vie
le voilà qui signe sa lettre de
transfert de pouvoirs au général
izumi état c'est donc en simple sénateur
à vie que le 16 octobre dernier pinochet
débarque à londres pour se faire opérer
d'une hernie discale
mais à madrid un juge espagnol baltasar
garzon saisie de multiples plaintes
demande l'arrestation et l'extradition
de pinochet soupçonné de génocide
torture et terrorisme protestations du
gouvernement chilien protestations de
pinochet qui argue de son immunité
diplomatique
mais déjà des exilés chiliens se
manifeste en suisse en france en suède
au danemark en belgique en allemagne de
partout influent les demandes
d'extradition
dans un premier temps la haute cour de
justice de londres annuler le mandat
d'arrêt contre pinochet elle autorise
même sa libération sous caution
les espagnols font appel et c'est à la
chambre des lords la plus haute instance
judiciaire britannique qu'il revient de
se prononcer aujourd'hui 25 novembre
elles jugent non valide
unité diplomatique dont se prévaut
pinochet conséquence elle ouvre la voie
à l'extradition vers l'espagne du
dictateur
l'heure de la méditation semble avoir
sonné pour le président nixon à la
surprise générale le chef de l'état
américain a annulé tous ses rendez-vous
du week-end pour se retirer seul dans sa
propriété du marineland
nul doute que monsieur nixon va
consacrer ses réflexions à la ferme
watergate qui fait grand bruit aux états
unis dernier épisode en date la
démission du directeur par intérim du
fbi haye qui est soupçonné d'avoir fait
brûler des documents compromettants
l'immeuble du watergate un ensemble de
bureaux et d'appartements dominant le
potomac dans le quartier chic de
washington depuis des semaines cet
immeuble est devenu un lieu de visite
car ce qui s'y est passé le 17 juin 72
menace le parti républicain
l'administration et directement le
président nixon qui a vu sa cote de
popularité baisser de 14%
ce jour là des policiers surprennent
dans les locaux du comité national
démocrate
cinq hommes gantés qui installent des
tables des coûte les auteurs de cette
opération d'espionnage politique sont
james mc cord ancien agent de la cia et
chef des services de sécurité du comité
pour la réélection du président gordon
lady ancien agent du fbi a hero award
inde dont la carrière dans l'espionnage
fut bien remplie arrêté et inculpé
leur procès s'ouvre le 10 janvier devant
la cour de washington les peines sont
très lourdes 21 ans prison poli 10 35
ans pointe et autant pour les autres qui
ont tous refusé de parler mais la
sentence est révisable dans les trois
mois si les inculpés se met à table
le ministre de la justice richard klein
dance a reçu mission du président nixon
de faire toute la lumière sur ce
scandale qui éclabousse la maison
blanche
karl enquête a révélé que l'entourage
même du président nixon était au courant
jour après jour presque d'heure en heure
de nouvelles révélations mettent en
cause des personnalités de premier plan
tels que le directeur intérimaire du fbi
haye où l'adjoint au secrétaire au
commerce
le président nixon a affirmé que toute
la lumière serait faite et que personne
ne bénéficierait de protection car c'est
le prestige même des états unis qui est
en jeu d'ores et déjà john mitchell
ancien ministre de la justice qui
dirigeait la campagne électorale du
président étant de ses amis à dieu ça
allait donner sa démission tout
maurice temps ancien secrétaire au
commerce mais la liste est loin d'être
close
je veux être enterré orvilliers je ne
veux ni fleurs ni couronnes ni monuments
funéraires bien sûr une simple dalle de
pierre de taille avec mon nom et les
dates de ma naissance et de ma mort
une messe sera dite à paris à saint
louis en l'île
elle sera chantée en grégorien signée
georges pompidou août 1972
telles sont les dernières volontés du
président de la république georges
pompidou écrite de sa main
il y a un an et demi après s'être rendus
cas de béthune où repose la dépouille
mortelle de monsieur pompidou après
avoir réuni à l'hôtel matignon son
gouvernement conseil de cabinet et après
en avoir informé monsieur alain poher
qui assure l'intérim de la présidence de
la république monsieur pierre messmer a
fait publier un communiqué indiquant
respectant la volonté du président
georges pompidou et à la demande de sa
famille une messe sera célébrée jeudi 4
avril à 11 heures en l'église saint
louis en l'île
la famille les membres du gouvernement
et les collaborateurs proches du
président assisteront seul à cette
cérémonie de caractère privé
l'inhumation aura lieu à orvilliers dans
la stricte intimité familiale
cette journée prendra un caractère de
recueillement national auquel le
gouvernement invite les français à
s'associer
deuxièmement une cérémonie solennelle
d'hommage au président georges pompidou
aura lieu le samedi 6 avril à 11 heures
à la cathédrale notre dame de paris en
présence des membres du gouvernement du
parlement des corps constitués et des
délégations étrangères
cette journée sera une journée de deuil
national
les administrations les établissements
d'enseignement seront fermés aucun
spectacle ne sera donnée troisièmement
conformément à l'usagé tous les drapeaux
seront mis en berne jusqu'à la fin du
mois
un registre est ouvert au palais de
l'elysée destinée à recueillir les
témoignages des français et des français
quatrièmement le conseil des ministres
se réunira le vendredi 5 avril au palais
de l'elysée ce conseil des ministres
donc sera présidée par monsieur alain
poher monsieur roger frey avait réuni
vers midi le conseil constitutionnel peu
après il donnait lui même lecture du
communiqué publié par le conseil
constitutionnel
je vais vous donner lecture de la
déclaration du conseil constitutionnel
le conseil constitutionnel constate à la
suite du décès le 2 avril 1974 à 21h de
monsieur georges pompidou président de
la république que sont réunies les
conditions prévues à l'article 7 de la
constitution relatives à l'exercice
provisoire les fonctions du président de
la république par le président du sénat
il déclare que s'ouvre à partir de cette
date le délai fixé par ce même article
pour l'élection du nouveau président de
la république
la présente déclaration sera publié au
journal officiel de la république
française
délibéré par le conseil constitutionnel
dans sa séance du 3 avril 1974 en
ouvrant la séance les prononcer
l'allocution suivante messieurs le
président de la république est mort je
ne dirai rien à cette heure des
sentiments personnels que j'éprouve un
sentiment qui me seraient dictés avant
tout par la peine profonde de perdre un
ami très cher acquis tant de souvenirs
me liés mais le président du conseil
constitutionnel à l'impérieux devoir de
rendre au chef de l'état qui vient de
disparaître
le vibrant hommage qui lui est dû sans
rien trahir du dernier entretien que
j'ai eu l'honneur d'avoir avec lui je
voudrais dire que sa préoccupation
dominante était celle de la france et de
son destin
c'est à elle
et aux français calais toutes ses
pensées
c'est pour elle et pour eux il fit
preuve jusqu'au dernier jour d'une
volonté et la courage qui force
l'admiration et qui le rendent à jamais
digne d'avoir été le premier des
français
j'exprime à drame georges pompidou à ses
enfants à sa famille notre profonde
émotion et je leur présente les
condoléances respectueuse et très
attristé du conseil constitutionnel
l'émotion dont parlait monsieur frais et
celle de tous les français surpris par
la nouvelle brutale annoncée hier soir
par un bref communiqué signé du
professeur vignalou et annonçant à 22
heures que le président de la république
était décédée à 21h on savait monsieur
pompidou malades ou pressentait la
gravité du mal sans savoir quelle il
était mais son courage qu'il a fait
rester jusqu'à la dernière minute à la
tête du pays pour assumer ses
responsabilités courage salué
unanimement france et à l'étranger
ce courage était telle qu'on ne pouvait
imaginer une issue tragique
si rapide dès que la mort de monsieur
pompidou fut rendu public des centaines
de parisiens se massaient devant le
palais de l'elysée où kate d'études tard
dans la nuit deux fenêtres allumées au
second étage
c'est ici que le président georges
pompidou est mort au terme d'une
souffrance qu'il avait su cacher avant
de sombrer dans le coma hier en fin
d'après midi
il ne s'était pas écoulée une demi heure
après l annonce du décès que déjà des
centaines de personnes se pressaient
quai de béthune
derrière ces barrières installées à la
hâte par les policiers des visages émus
et parfois stupéfait pour respecter le
deuil de madame pompidou de son fils
docteur alain pompidou
la rue avait été interdite à la
circulation puis à l'aube après la pluie
un silence impressionnant entouré cet
appartement qui était encore plus que la
maison d'orvilliers le vrai refuge de
monsieur et madame pompidou
ici seuls entre elles et ami intime le
chef de l'état repose maintenant sur son
lit de mort
et du salon bibliothèque tandis que des
ouvriers installent à l'entrée du numéro
24 des tentures funéraire
il y avait autant de monde cette nuit
devant le palais de l'elysée les mêmes
visages attristé des gens qui attendent
on le sait quoi ce qu'ils ont vu ça les
aura peut-être étonné car déjà en pleine
nuit on venait récupérer les dossiers
les archives personnelles du président
pompidou
c'est pourtant l'usa
ouais
oui
comme celle usage aussi les plus proches
collaborateurs du président pompidou qui
se sont encore réunies ce matin
proposeront de présenter leur démission
émotion tout aussi intense dans le petit
village d'orvilliers près de paris où le
chef de l'état et met à se reposer dans
sa maison blanche c'est également ici
que vos tech georges pompidou écouter le
maire d'orvilliers je suis rempli de
chagrin
comme tous les français envers un grand
français qui était en même temps un
citoyen d'orvilliers c'est assumer ces
fonctions avec un courage exemplaire
jusqu'au bout c'est à cajar sur les
bords du lot qu'avant d'être président
de la république georges pompidou avait
été élu conseiller municipal il avait
refusé d'être maire de cajarc car
disait-il
ceux qui travaillent ici doivent en
assumer les fonctions georges pompidou
georges pompidou était alors premier
ministre très amicale
car monsieur pompidou d'être un homme
affable serviable toujours prêt à rendre
service et des deux bons conseils
généraux supérieurs comme il a très peu
en france
notre pays cage à l'autre la france
on va regretter son départ subit dans le
cantal enfin voici montboudif son
village natal les parents de georges
pompidou sont enterrés ici
le président ne reposera pas auprès
d'eux comme vous le savez c'est la terre
d'orvilliers qu'il est qu'il recueillera
loin de là mais si près de sa maison
blanche qu'il aimait tant
autre séquence choc qui restera je crois
dans l'oeil et la mémoire de tous les
téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 le
couronnement fastueux et napoléonien de
l'ancien sous-officier de l'armée
française le cap décembre 1977 journée
universellement historique journée qui
verra se dérouler un événement sans
précédent dans les annales de l'afrique
centrale à savoir le couronnement de sa
majesté bokassa 1er empereur de
centrafrique
il était déjà un maréchal secrétaire
général du parti unique il était
président à vie ce 4 décembre 1977 jean
bedel bokassa devient bokassa 1er ultime
péripétie d'une carrière politique fort
mouvementée peut-être même faut-il
remonter à son enfance pour comprendre
cet homme qui allait faire sourire le
monde entier avant de défier l'afrique
le futur empereur étaient devenus
orphelins à 6 ans après que son père
étaient des passionnés à mort et que sa
mère se suicider très vite à l'âge de 18
ans et choisi la carrière militaire et
s'engage dans l'armée française la
seconde guerre mondiale l'indochine
allait lui permet de glaner de
nombreuses décorations et d'en sortir en
1962 avec le grade de capitaine dans la
nuit du 31 décembre 65
il passe à l'action il renverse son
cousin david dacko celui là même qui l'a
renversé hier soir dès lors jean bedel
bokassa à les multiplier les contacts
avec la france son pays d'adoption
disait-il avec le général de gaulle en
particulier qu'il appelait papa
mais c'est aussi à cette époque que sa
mégalomanie allait se révéler au grand
jour avec une série d'incidents
sanglants
ce sont d'abord les bastonnades de
juillet 72 le maréchal président conduit
lui-même un détachement de soldats armés
de matraques pour corriger les voleurs
détenus dans cette prison
bilan 3 morts et 42 blessés on cesse
alors de sourire jean bedel bokassa
devient peu à peu l'un des dictateurs
les plus tyranniques et les plus
sanglants du continent africain mais il
faudra attendre avril dernier pour
mesurer l'ampleur de sa cruauté
parmi ces enfants qui chantent le nom de
leur empereur il allait y en avoir une
centaine d' assassiner pour avoir refusé
de porter l'uniforme une commission
denquête composé d'africains allait
confirmer les faits
cette pratique systématique de la
torture était décriée dans le monde
entier et en 1977 lorsque jean pierre
elkabbach alain duhamel avait rencontré
il lui avait posé la question de ces
bastonnades et de ses oreilles coupées
dans l' empire centrafricain écoutez
plutôt la réponse de l'empereur
aujourd'hui des six
et le cas des oreilles coupées une
niaque eu qu'un seul cas parce qu'il
s'agissait d'une bande de voleurs ils
étaient 47
ils étaient organisés ils étaient armés
ils avaient dévalisé le les
centrafricains de plein jour le
centrafricain et les étrangers de plein
jour c'est pour cette raison que en une
seule fois
j'ai donné cette les sons mais après
j'ai retiré les mesures ça n'existe plus
mais qu'on ne se fait plus ça ne se fait
plus ça ne se fera plus ça ne se fera
plus du tout c'est un engagement que
l'empereur que c'était un engagement que
j'ai pris et puis un engagement qui
était cuit il ya une ordonnance qui le
dit et pas seulement parce qu'il ya le
couronnement dans quelques temps non du
tout du tout non je vous dis c'est
affaire de la est coupée celle
manifestée le jour où il ya eu des
problèmes qui étaient posées bastonner
c'est la même chose et s'était
accompagnée de c'était en cas c'est à
dire le même jour il ya eu ces mêmes qui
ont eu les oreilles coupées ont été
d'abord bastonner ça c'est sûr avant
d'avoir les oreilles coupées
ah vraiment nous sommes trop gâtés et ça
commence à suffire
nous n'avons pas de pétrole mais nous
avons des pétroliers au large et qui
s'échouent sur nos côtes bretonnes pour
abîmer ce que nous avons de plus beau et
ruiné la saison des pêcheurs nous ne
sommes pas loin du record du monde de
bolt de la pollution depuis ce matin de
la pollution marine en tout cas avec ce
pétrolier libérien dont l'armateur est
américain et l'équipage italien et qui
s'est échoué sur les récifs à deux
kilomètres au large de portsall sur les
côtes sur la côte du finistère sur la
côte nord du finistère 15 km de côtes
serait déjà pollué les fonds marins les
parcs à huîtres sans parler du site
touristique sont touchés ou gravement
menacées par la marée noire qui s'écoule
lentement parait-il mais sûrement de
deux des cuves du pétrolier ce pétrolier
c'est l'amoco cadiz
c'est le quatrième a endommagé la
bretagne en onze ans avant lui il y a eu
le torrey canyon l'olympique bradbury le
bollène ils circulent en permanence 140
pétroliers de plus de 200 mille tonnes
sur toutes les mers et la bretagne en a
assez d'être la côte de ces naufrages de
ces gros bâtiment le dépotoir du pétrole
brut l'amoco cadiz a eu une avarie de
gouvernail et hier matin c'est imparable
sur un tank air de cette taille un
remorqueur est venu à son secours mais
les files en casser la tempête a brossé
le bâtiment sur les récifs
depuis c'est l'état major de crise
contre la pollution les gens de la côte
sont au désespoir ils veulent qu'on
mette le feu aux pétroliers messone
détruirait que 20 à 30% du pétrole
contenu dans ses flancs on a mis en
place des barrages flottants
on envisage tous les moyens de lutte
contre la marée noire mais les récifs
empêche le blé bateau d'intervenir comme
on voudrait le bateau est coupé en deux
depuis ce matin il va falloir pompé sans
doute
l'équipage a été évacué pas de victimes
le capitaine italien pleurait les
bretons aussi pleurait encore plus que
lui j'ai appris cet après midi que si
les pétroliers passés si près des côtes
dans un passage réputés difficiles
depuis toujours
c'était pour des questions de
rentabilité les armateurs se refuse à
effectuer le détour qui s'imposerait il
ya des moments où il faut choisir et se
montrer ferme n'est ce pas bref c'est
insupportable ça dépasse l'entendement
les images que vous venez de voir ont
été prises très tôt ce matin par alain
darchy
bord d'un hélicoptère de la marine
nationale ce sont les taux de premières
maintenant le reportage de robert werner
c'est une catastrophe deux fois plus
importante que celle du torrey canyon
cela tout le monde le sait ici le amoco
cadiz contenait deux fois plus trente
mille tonnes se sont déjà déversées dans
la mer et elle gagne ses jolies plages
du nord finistère
cet après midi tous les habitants de
portsall 2000 habitants étaient sur le
port tout le monde regarde et cela et
nappes de pétrole s'avance et l'épave de
l'amoco cadiz et à quelques centaines de
mètres seulement des côtes
les vagues sont noirs noirs aussi les
pensées des pêcheurs et des commerçants
de cette station balnéaire
en effet après le torrey canyon 80 mille
tonnes à la mer et l'olympique braderie
des centaines de tonnes à la mer et le
pollen 2000 tonnes c'en est vraiment
trop mais ces nappes de pétrole n'ont
cependant pas le même aspect que le
mazout du torrey canyon elles sont moins
visqueuse et on suppose ici que la
cargaison était préchauffé c'est
possible en effet puisque le pétrolier
devait décharger en partie au havre et
l'opération est plus aisé dans ce cas là
les hommes de l'amoco cadiz qui
transportait donc 230 mille tonnes de
pétrole en provenance du moyen-orient
ont été évacués dans des conditions
périlleuses cette nuit car la mer était
très forte
vous savez que le bateau avait une panne
ans l'a remorqué
mais le câble a lâché vers 20h30 hier
soir ce qui a fait échouer d'immenses
amoco cadiz par marée haute sur les
rochers une des citernes a été éventrée
puis la salle des machines s'est ouverte
à la mer sous le choc à 2000 milles de
l'île vierge le pétrole liquide
s'échapper à partir de ce moment là la
cote ici est très belle aux écueils
innombrables et nappes ne seront pas
brûler mes pompes et on n'utilisera pas
de détergents pour éviter de trop
détruire la flore mais pour les
habitants de la région
c'est une très dure épreuve
pourquoi est-ce que le navire accidenté
était il si près des côtes
il faut savoir que pour venir du sud en
particulier alors quand on est un grand
pétrolier il faut doubler le cap
finistère où et sans les casques est
passé dans le pas de calais en chacun de
ces points
des dispositifs de séparation de trafic
ont été instituées sur un plan
international et qui prévoit de faire
une route montante une route descendante
avec interdiction formelle ou d'utiliser
les zones réservées à la montée pour la
descente et les six pros clan et il est
plus facile la navigation traditionnelle
en est la preuve le rôle des phares le
rôle des radios phare dans la navigation
et la preuve de se positionner de façon
précise plus près des côtes que plus
loin et à l'intérieur d'une route
recommandé il faut connaître avec
précision sa position faute de quoi l'on
pourrait prendre
passez moi l'expression une route en
sens interdit